your dad always said I'm going to go out
probably banging your mom he said boys
when I go I'm going to be making love to
your mother and he did he called a shot
he did do it didn't he 6:30 a.m. on a
Monday morning do you believe there's
something Cosmic about that like your
dad knew how he was going to die and he
actually did it and he did did he have a
heart attack your had a heart privation
yeah and then your mom said I want my
man to be carried out of here nude
because I want them to see the gift that
was Jim
MCC I mean he must had a big right
I mean is that what she was talking
about yeah the paramedic is covering him
and all the neighbors are out in the
street and he's going out the garage
down so you know what's the sensible
thing to do at 7: a.m. covering my mom's
out there half naked ripping the sheet
off him get that sheet off of him you're
going to see how big Jim went out I hope
he had a boner at that point I do too